واعاده السلام
قامت روسيا بالاعلان الخاص بها وقرروا
انهم ممكن ان يستخدموا الارهاب من جديد
حتى يصل الى ما لم يستطيع الوصول له خلال
9 اشهر
اصابه الصواريخ كيم ومختلف المدن في
الثالث الساعه الثالثه
ضربت الصواريخ المدن وفي
ايضا وفي تونس وفي فرانك وفي خارج كيف
الراكده وفي كريبري
وفيبل طازه وفي الساعه 4:00 جيتومر من
جديد وكييف وحوديسا ونكلايف وتر نوبل وكيف
من جديد هناك قتلى وجرحى
نحن نعبر عن عداءنا للضحايا واقاربهم هناك
الكهرباء التي تتقطع الان في مختلف ال
المناطق والكثير من المنازل بدون كهرباء
واصعب ظروف متواجده
في الفيف وفي كيف وفي بعض المناطق لا
نستطيع مد التدفئه للمنازل وتتقطع ايضا
خطوط الكهرباء والانترنت
هو هناك
محطات
ذريه توقفت فيها بعض المولدات وهذه
النتائج
متعمده من قبل العدو هذا هو الرد الروسي
لاندونيسيا ومختلف الدول التي تتحدث عن
السلام ان روسيا تقول للعالم انها تريد ان
تستمر في هذه الحرب الان يجب ان ننتظر
الرد الدولي
تحدثنا ان الارهاب لن يتوقف على حدود
اوكرانيا الان في مندوبيه واليوم الصواريخ
الروسيه اصابه بولندا عصابه هذه الدوله
الصديقه وهنا ضحايا ونحن نعبر عن عداءنا
الاخوه البولنديين كم من المرات تحدثنا عن
ان الدوله الارهابيه التي تتوقف على حدود
اوكرانيا ان بولندا والبلطي
وقت ان يصل لها العدوان يجب ان نضع
الارهابيين في مكانهم
ويجب ان نعلم ان الصواريخ الروسيه قد تصل
الى اي مكان ضربات صاروخيه باراضي النيتو
ان هذا يهدد الامن العالمي يجب ان نتعامل
مع هذا بالافعال واريد ان اقول للاخوه
البولنديين اوكرانيا سوف تدعمكم دائما
الاحرار
ان الخوف لن يصيبنا وانا شاكر جميع
الشركاء الذين يساعدونا على الدفاع عن
السماء الاوكرانيه
والذين
دعمون
بالكثير من الانظمه
استرها كده
ضربات صاروخيه وضربات بالمسيرات وانا شاكر
للشركاء الذين يؤمنون بانظمه دفاع جوي
تساعدنا بضرب هذه الهجمات
وانا شاكر لقوات الدفاع الجوي شكرا للجميع
قوات الانقاذ وقوات الطاقه الهندسيه الذين
يعملون على اعاده الحياه للمواطنين
ويعملون على تجديد الاعمار التي الاعمال
التي تمر في جميع المناطق سوف
بروجراليين
روسيا في ارض المعركه انها ترهبنا وترهب
الجميع سوف نفعل كل ما بوسعنا حتى نوقف
روسيا المجد لكل من يدافع عن الحريه
والمسجد من يعمل والمجد للضحايا والمجد
لاوكرانيا